hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is our you garbage I am your host H
Foley coming at you from the home studio
here and beautiful Astoria Queens my
co-host about a thousand miles away from
me coming at you from an undisclosed
location somewhere in southern New
Jersey my good pal Kevin James Ryan
everybody hey what's up down here in the
bunker baby you know living to fight
another day gathering my [ __ ] I'm
playing a garden out back making my own
turnips you know who knows how this
thing's store and squirrel meat in the
freezer I know man yeah what's up
everybody happy to be here thanks for
tuning in you know quick little business
make sure you rate review subscribe you
know you can subscribe on YouTube all
the videos full videos of the episodes
are on youtube so you can subscribe and
watch them there yeah happy to be here
buddy yeah do us a [ __ ] favor will
you we're taking over here help us out
our incredibly awesome guests that we
have today we're so happy to add in here
ladies and gentleman score this real
quick all right
Legion of skanks podcast one of the
biggest podcasts out there real ass
podcast the hosts of owner gas digital
network podcast [ __ ] Network killing
it the creator of skank fest and the
soon-to-be skank fat south lazy
gentleman if there's a [ __ ] self-made
man out there we got him on the [ __ ]
line right now most of you bozos out
there should take a page out of this
kid's book ladies and gentlemen the
Puerto Rican rattlesnake
Louis J Gomez ladies and gentlemen thank
you thank you guys I really appreciate
the be very undeserved intro okay [ __ ]
loser I'm sitting here at my shitty
[ __ ] bedroom with stains all over my
bed I know I know I just saw I just saw
your unmade bed oh yeah as you were
crawling towards the pillows I was like
we we are seeing way too much of each
other yeah I will say this I was
expecting a little more out of the
[ __ ] boo Drive not the dad that IKEA
set up he got behind it a business owner
made it nice I mean it's fine it's not
bad but it's like it's I have a hard
time
like the only reason I have anything
nice at all is because I have a
seven-year-old and I remember like up
until the I probably start having
memories like I'm sort of like my first
memories when we're like four right yeah
you think back to your earliest [ __ ]
memory you're probably four years old so
right up until like his fourth birthday
I was living like a [ __ ] heroin
addict advanced and loose baby ain't
gonna [ __ ] know who gives a [ __ ]
he had no memories of anything before
that date I mean I would [ __ ] put
cigarettes out on this mother [ __ ] no
refrigerators smoke crack and house
nobody gave a [ __ ] but then right before
HR 4 I started getting my [ __ ] together
a little bit so yeah yeah yeah who the
[ __ ] makes their bed as well what's
wrong with you made bed what type of
sociopath gets up and makes his bed
every morning I've never made my bed
ever I'm just saying I didn't think I'd
ever see your bed that's all yes I'm
just watching you I was just expecting a
little more out of a headboard I mean
you got like the basic IKEA I thought
you'd have like a [ __ ] nice headboard
actually I'm actually really impressed
with my headboard I didn't own a
headboard I [ __ ] the fat chick in my
bed maybe a month and a half ago crank
man again yeah and I broke my bed frame
it was like you know it really it wasn't
good it was it was if you look at it
look like two Mexican wrestlers going at
it [ __ ] power yeah it was like yeah
and then I bought a headboard and I took
a lot of time and the first thing you
attack about my room is my head boy and
now I'm very self-conscious well I was I
was just I was just I was just picturing
something more
I thought your room was gonna look like
gene Simmons room or something like that
there would be like snake pillars going
up and like a canopy over the bed I want
to do I want to invest more into my
apartment either two bedroom one and a
half bathroom in Harlem I have a really
good deal right now mike is just nice
not leaving this place until I purchased
something there you go but I'm also
[ __ ] so
now that I got wha now that I got you
know certain things going on and you
know I can afford certain things like I
really want to turn my half bathroom and
do a steam room and oh my god every
person in my life that isn't a [ __ ] is
like dude you're not doing a five
thousand dollar renovation on a bathroom
that you have to go and turn back once
you like leave your lease and I'm like
nah dude that's all I want is a [ __ ]
steam room in that half bathroom now I
say go for it a hundred percent a nice
steam in the middle of winter
get a little shits goin that's all right
now my only literally now and I'm being
very very true about this my only
problem with coronavirus is that I can't
see my nail I can't name another problem
with it not because you can't go to
equinox is that where you go Equinox
this guy and let me tell you something
Kippy points in his favor
the half-bath really moves you up a
notch when you got that extra half a
bath a powder room if you will [ __ ]
class do you want which one do I just
say which one [ __ ] power move right
there you wanna [ __ ] impress a chick
which bathroom which one there you go
class but didn't I think Todd Lynn did
that like didn't he do like the I think
it's a famous story he died got her so
so he can't refute the story but he had
a you know you got a source development
deal 150 K and he went and put like
eighty thousand dollars in renovations
into his apartment like like coming to
America like you got a hot tub in it and
that's looking great they came to renew
the lease and they were like I got the
TV that comes up out of the dresser yeah
yeah so the super sit having a hot tub
in the middle of the floor all I want is
a [ __ ] steam room in my home this is
the only thing I did I be gonna do it
more and more I go to the deride masoom
and you've gone at some point the
Russian Turkish baths down all of course
that's [ __ ] great man there's nothing
better than that place that's how I
justified my equinox membership because
I was going to the Russian Turkish bath
houses like four times a month
times a month and I was like this is
costing me almost as much as an equinox
membership and you don't miss a gym
membership yeah exactly so now I get a
[ __ ] steam room and I get hot gay
guys as well
the only a [ __ ] old Russian dudes at
the Russian Turkish baths big handy good
rush it well if that was open right now
oh if I would say we should all go spits
right after this podcast let's just go
get naked have a little [ __ ] uh what
is it like as a young boy they're like
massages you in the steam room the one
the one that the one really hot sauna
yeah yeah yeah well if that thing was
open right now there'd be like 400,000
people with the corona because that
place is a [ __ ] germ Factory that
really is a disgusting place they do not
keep it clean but that's still nice with
the AIDS breakout in the 80s right that
was like that was like the epicenter no
yeah cause it's all [ __ ] gay dudes
[ __ ] each other that place was the
epicenter of it I thought it was a
Chuckie Cheese in that and also comedian
Sam Rubin Dolph he had a membership
there so he would go during the week
when it's just like it's dudes only and
he said when you go there's the one I
don't know what one it is like the one
down on the left
I don't know if it's like the song or
whatever it's one of them where they got
they hang a towel they cover the light
with the towel there we walk in and
don't see the light I mean it's like
those dudes you know blowing each other
again that's the [ __ ] party room
right there that's that's in being gay
it's cleaning up there the magic hair in
the world
you think about that you're just [ __ ]
cuz like nobody can like hit on in steam
rooms probably a dozen times like
aggressively like a guy will just
[ __ ] open up his towel and have a
[ __ ] boner and know him oh yeah for
sure only optical isn't but I thought
Equinox would be would be freaking out
about that no dude well they started
freaking out about it a couple years ago
because there was a big class-action
lawsuit because a bunch of [ __ ]
straight
kids who like you feel weird like I feel
like it's just weird things I'm going
like I'm not you know so I'm cool just
so you know it's not your lifestyle
they'd have a problem it's you trying to
rape me just wanna point that out so you
feel this weird shame and it's also like
I'm not a woman so it's also not the
same thing as like a woman having a guy
exposed himself I got [ __ ]
like she knows at that moment like oh
that guy wanted to just [ __ ] drag me
into the [ __ ] yeah that's actually
powerless yeah for me I'm gonna [ __ ]
you know I'll light up most of the guys
that have tried to [ __ ] you yeah but now
you know how it feels a little bit you
know what I mean you get an idea what
women go through and hey you got a tight
little body on your kid don't be
prancing around in your short shorts and
nobody been making a great short shorts
you're asking for it we're naked we're
in a sea there you go so but here's the
thing it's sort of not like a woman
because all I get out of it and we could
admit it or we cannot admit it but all I
get is the feeling of feeling somewhat
flattered right yeah there's no real
rent yeah there's a little scuzzy and a
little like all right buddy put your
[ __ ] [ __ ] away all right I'm not your
[ __ ] plaything [ __ ] right but by the
way nice piece so but women have the
feeling of like oh [ __ ] you know this
guy if he wants to can hurt me so
there's a feeling of powerlessness that
you don't have the only way I imagine
this you could probably imagine when you
walk through a black neighborhood oh
yeah thank you
yeah I live in the Haight see that wall
it's like I'm not I'm [ __ ] checking
my six every two seconds you know one of
my heads on a swivel yeah I'm a mark but
exactly that's you actually kind of feel
you know much more what it's like to
feel like a woman that I know what it's
like like woman because I could [ __ ] him
I will you can walk in both worlds
Lucy Gomez walks in both worlds any
three guys that I'm trying to [ __ ] me
equinox I could probably take none of
them they're usually older feeble gay
guys that that are I mean they're never
like
you know I mean how many [ __ ] really
tough gay guys are there anyway i mean
i'm sure there are like some badass but
I know there's MMA fighters that like
are gay are there engine MMA fighters in
the UFC not in the UFC but there's
definitely a couple that are out but I
think you yeah I feel like Luis is
saying he never gets hit on by the guys
he wants yeah there's no dudes that can
just grab me and you know really if
you're gonna bang a dude you want to be
banged by a [ __ ] man right so my son
is in here Shawn I want a [ __ ] real
babe but you want a beefy dude on top of
you you don't want no [ __ ] little
[ __ ] so that's sort of the issue like
maybe it's just that I haven't been
presents with the right guy you guys are
right there you go mm-hmm
you never know I've never I always I
always thought about how that must feel
like what you're saying with like women
when like you know there's that [ __ ]
threat of like well this [ __ ] you
know could be some huge animal and he
could just [ __ ] grab me I remember
like the first time in New York that I
realized how bad like catcalling wasn't
like how [ __ ] up it was you know like
in the 40s and 50s you hear like hey
Dollface are you doing I was right
behind this [ __ ] this woman she was
walking shared her headphones on so she
didn't hear the guy but this dude was
walking towards us the other way and as
he got by her this was his exact words
he goes damn you got those dick sucking
lips I was in Jesus [ __ ] Christ
open up with her how you doing or
something hurts pal you're gonna lead
off with that like what the [ __ ] yeah I
mean it's that you know yes fine
I don't know that cat going it's hard
for me to wrap my mind around how cat
callings are real big problems like my
mother or something like that is my
mother killed herself with heroin my dad
was stabbed to death when I was 4 years
old I can't wrap my mind around it it's
just there's I have no empathy for a
woman who's like oh my god my day was so
horrible three guys said something to me
on the street I'm like they didn't hit
you they didn't [ __ ] take your purse
they didn't
what do you don't think I don't think we
need to do the test I think he's garbage
without the streets baby and if you see
that in less affluent neighborhoods if
you go to really like go to these
[ __ ] white neighborhoods white
neighborhoods freaking out people are
losing their minds and then you go to
the you know more [ __ ] your neighbors
and this is why like you know they'll
show you pictures of people in the
subway it's like it when you go to the
subway in the Bronx people are just
going to work doing I don't want to say
I'm going not going to listen to the
fact that there's a virus I that's that
I've been illegal [ __ ] least I'm
supposed to be yeah there's 15 people in
a two-bedroom yeah it's like they got
bigger problems and it just and I know
that it's irresponsible to say it's like
I you know I just I can't you know I
understand that side of it as well I do
get it no makes sense because you're
gonna get where you're coming from
they're going I might get Corona next
week or in two weeks but like if I don't
have the rent on the first like or like
I need to you know I need money to feed
my kids and [ __ ] like that no they got
different problems yeah I mean I you
know my son's mother is completely out
of work right now that it's just half
the [ __ ] income come I mean what on
the same household but it's still like
still go to the same place yeah yeah I
mean my son has half of the income
coming into his life I should you know
put it that way so you know it's it
sucks but luckily you know some of us
[ __ ] I didn't have to swear John a
headboard so I got a little bit of a
cushion is the kid putting the screws
here for the cash as you know what's up
shaking you down
he doesn't understand money he's you
know he doesn't understand what the
difference between two five hundred
dollars or five dollars he's a [ __ ]
child
all right probably so let's jump into
the game here we're gonna ask you a
series of questions answer them to the
to the best of your ability you have
anything to add to the questions please
feel free do you hold on do you think
you're garbage I mean you know you you
had bit of a different upbringing I mean
your dad was murdered and your your mom
died of heroin
like it's not you didn't have the
traditional suburban upbringing you know
hooray who raised you
wolves my mom raised me but she was
really shitty and abusive and I I think
that it depends on how you define
garbage I think that deep down in my
core my foundation was built off of a
real big pile of [ __ ] garbage and I
think that you'll never escape that but
it's just that I mean it depends on how
you define garbage like currently
garbage I don't think so well yeah they
were starting to cut y'all but that's
the way we look at it it doesn't have to
do with you know economics or like how
you grew up it's it's some some people
grew up surrounded by garbage and that
made them realize that they don't ever
want to be garbage like I assume now
that you have the place like your
apartments [ __ ] tip-top you take care
of your son to the tenth degree you make
sure everything's under control I mean
you can kind of see it in your work
ethic you know I mean you couldn't be
you know like a piece of [ __ ] and
accomplish what you've accomplished you
know building building a business and
building a [ __ ] you know a network
you couldn't do that so you could have
learned from Romo Weinstein did all
right with it I think you know
characteristic and a trait of a piece of
garbage is maybe being norsu Cystic or a
sociopath and I think that you can be
very very successful Walt yeah that's
that's actually you would argue it's a
key to being supports of elements of
that are a key to being successful yeah
you could hurt people you know you could
have no empathy for people that you're
supposed to love and take care of you
could you know you can get to a very
very high level and still make garbage
decisions do garbage things I would I
look at like if a person is garbage it's
it's almost like it's not about where
they're at economically no you know it's
in spite of that right the in fact it
would even accentuate it more if
somebody would act a certain way like if
somebody is that is more affluent and I
would give them less leeway to be
garbage so I would consider them even
more garbage than a person that reacted
the same way that was less affluent this
is a bigger of a jump yeah there's a
certain oh yeah
yeah so it just sort of depends on what
so I think it's about who you are how
you react what you do to certain
situations that would define whether or
not you're garbage and I think it would
be I think I'm somewhat polarizing in
this category I think you have people
that listen to our shows there's people
growing right now like yeah Louis is a
good dude you know he's you know such
friends yeah it's a little more I mean
especially the game it's like it's more
lighthearted it's like growing up the
Jew you know how this or that it's not
you know it's turn it into a [ __ ]
episode of SVU I'm I'm gonna ask you if
you like skim milk or not that's you're
talking about [ __ ] lex luthor's [ __ ]
over here give your kid name-brand juice
boxes that's as far as that is true it's
like it's definitely you know it's a you
there's garbage people for short it's
not it's not like actions yes it's more
based on kind of be he's sucking you
down this rabbit hole you're following
me Chris Cuomo over here let's go hit
the fun button baby come on I got one hi
let's let's get started you Phil do you
want to do some of the easier ones up
front well I'm not gonna ask him about
his childhood now what the [ __ ] is the
thing is the basic sir sir
they don't really apply to city kid
stuff like something that we always
start off with people Louis is what
grocery store did you go to all right
what's the name of the grocery store
growing up that you went to shop right
Oh Jesse Jesse place went to shop right
it was yeah my mom worked at said shop
right
I used to work in a grocery store -
that's right I worked at Shepherd -
actually I worked in the the [ __ ]
deli meat section the Delian section
when I was there it was always the kids
that had weed or that would buy you beer
when you were under the deli if you were
in the deli section as like a 19 or 20
year old you were [ __ ] you had made
some bad turns don't buy meat from a
[ __ ] supermarket deli section
I don't think I ever washed my hands in
high school like once I don't thought of
remember a single time where I sat down
to wash my hands now I'm showered and
I've cleaned myself I swam in pools and
lakes and things hoping for sure but
bragging clean well let me ask you this
since you brought that up and you work
there and I'm not innocent of this
either entirely or my associates weren't
innocent of it did you ever do anything
to anything you ever pee in anything and
either piss in the potato salad or dip
your nuts in the [ __ ] corned beef or
anything like that not at ShopRite
no over at Acme don't [ __ ] go there
well I worked at a Mexican restaurant
called Fiesta calculon I've worked every
day since I was 11 years old I was a kid
before that since I was like that was my
son's age my son's seven dude and seven
I was knocking on people's doors asked
him if I could rake their lawns you know
you know do our jobs
same thing here same thing would get me
- yeah yeah I just you know I I was so
poor growing up and you know I was
having I was also very aware talking
about my kid didn't know it doesn't
understand money like I was so aware
that we were poor at that young of an
age and making money was something that
was sort of on my mind so I I always had
a job but when I was 15 years old there
weren't the fiestas can't clean which
was a Mexican restaurant and there was
like a [ __ ] just an [ __ ] of a guy
like that's like an old Jewish guy that
was just being shitty - every Mexican
there were and I wasn't Mexican I was a
big quarter Rican kid I was like and I
was a busboy but the whole team I mean I
think the manager the owner everybody
was involved everybody knew what was
going on they filled up their water
pitcher from the toilet
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] garbage but that is [ __ ]
awesome I love that baby the whole dude
literally I went into it cool
[ __ ] and put it on the table
tell [ __ ] right there everytime Trump
talks about the wall I'm like you know
what yeah yes the Cancun or Cancun
Fiesta well that's why dude you never
[ __ ] with [ __ ] the waiter you never
[ __ ] with people in the kitchen you
never act like a [ __ ] [ __ ] with
that stuff because they will [ __ ]
poison you I you know I know this and I
wish I could control myself but in the
moment when I'm spending money in a
place once I bring myself back to being
this little poor kid and you know and it
goes around like you know [ __ ] hard
I've worked or die [ __ ] this waiter it's
gonna forget my [ __ ] breadsticks it's
not like that that's car not right
that's garbage you're justifying if
you're justifying the money you spend on
breadsticks killing Ricky Bobby's dad
just causing a fight for no reason I
think back to shop right my mom working
at the [ __ ] register just bleep bleep
bleep I was like dude I [ __ ] I worked
way too hard and then I know they go
back and they just you know [ __ ]
shove each red stick into their [ __ ]
pull it out wait so but really you're
that guy so I'm waiting on you you order
a cheeseburger okay I bring it out
cheese don't eat it please you already
agree on the walkout can this make it to
my plates Louis you might be able to see
I just noticed before you got it he's so
fat he doesn't have ears anymore the
promise fully you would be handsome I'm
noticing from this angle did you need to
lose weight because maybe a handsome the
vampire you looking [ __ ] gorgeous you
can be goth dude put some [ __ ]
eyeliner on Foley [ __ ] rock it out
she all he needs us to lose some [ __ ]
weight give me a hot Gavi vampire dude
he's got the good head of hair all
you got a good frame on you your ass you
know you are athletic [ __ ] 20 decades
ago but mm-hmm you can pull it you could
pull it together and then the night dude
you're you're in your 40s you could get
it together
and have Bobby has one in one run where
they're like you know what dude I
[ __ ] there on keto they got a post in
there hashtag in there in the gym
folders gonna have one of those in the
next couple years I hope if he makes it
through he's also he's also living in
Queens that's like the height of [ __ ]
Corona he's got at least two or three
through pre-existing conditions I'm sure
of it I think I thought if their own if
I get the Rona and I survive it that
might take me down at least 20 pounds
the [ __ ] he's gonna put a bullet in
the first day that's the problem when we
get guests that are really good at like
fun fun to riff with we get off it's
okay more garbage you're probably more
fun with absolutely yes for sure you
ever I got a question for you have you
ever almost or gotten into a fight with
another kid's dad so like meaning
meaning my kid like because of your kid
yeah yeah yeah you're not not I got into
a fight with a guy who happen to be a
father right you're saying like yeah
yeah because of the kid you're on the
playground with the kid some kid pushes
your kid the dad doesn't do anything
about it you got to go over
[ __ ] straighten them out no but I
mean I you know there's been moments
where there's been like you know the you
know the kids being a dick on the
playground you kind of look and I've
never had to really deal with that for
the most part you know you're not
dealing I also you know we go to
playgrounds in the Upper West Sider
schools on the Upper West Side it's like
you know it's a different class of
personally dealing with as garbagey of
people up there yeah no one's not throw
down and on you know a team extra
fighter you yeah Lois Walton they get
their kids like I time to go and start
packing up their toys and [ __ ] already
so my son looks like an after-school
program two days a week and I was going
to pick him up one day it was like five
o'clock and I this is a very lowest
thing okay and fine okay whatever I will
admit that I'm [ __ ] crazy right I
have my cell phone I have like Apple pay
so I pay for like a pay for a cab with
Apple pay okay
and so my [ __ ] thing came up so I go
to get out of the cab and I go to pay
for it with Apple pay when the thing
says it's declined it just says like
error code and I'm like yeah I was like
I'm gonna keep on doing it like four
five times was like there's a kiss being
declined and I was like stop being
declined I'm telling it like I checked
the balance and now by the way now I'm
late picking up my son I'm like three
four minutes late this point you know
and I'm on the corner and there's
schools like halfway down the block so
this guy's buddy I don't know what you
more to tell you I don't have my I
didn't have my wallet on me I just had
what my cell phone I was like I can't do
anything I was like there's no ATM to go
to there's no nothing I was like either
it accepts this or you gotta get to
shit-faced so he's arguing with me so I
was like all right cool
see you later I get up I get out of the
cab so he gets out of the cab that's
what's following me and he gets on the
phone he's calling 9-1-1 he's like this
guy's trying and i'm on this my my son's
blah blah school and parents are walking
by and [ __ ] [ __ ] so you're gonna end
up on the hood of a hood of a cop car I
still love you I still love you
[Laughter]
my kids not gonna understand the nuance
if the Apple pay not work and my kids
only gonna take it like my dad didn't
want to pay for this [ __ ] cabin yeah
again yeah I can't let my kids see this
[ __ ] cab driver okay there's no way
my kids see this up so my buddy get the
[ __ ] away from you if you don't get away
from I'm gonna break your [ __ ] jaw
I'm threatening this guy down
now I'm robbing him and I'm Freddie
multiple crimes are being committed this
is weeks ago this is right before the
fire separate this is years ago this is
so me put the [ __ ] away from he's like
he's like our see he's trying to tease
me now people are starting to line up
with cell phones and oh my god are you
still trying to be polite to the other
parents I gave mrs. Fleming good to see
[Laughter]
my kid so I ended up literally running
after him and chasing him because every
time I'd come here way back up cause he
was a [ __ ] running up there chasing
she's running away from take off my
heart and jacket really quick so he just
used me from behind I can do this so I
ran after him he runs I run some ladies
like what do you doing Starla [ __ ] you
lady much I gotta get my bone school I'm
sweating and [ __ ] nervous I'm like
ten minutes late and it's a hey Dad I
can turn so we walk up the walk will you
it on the other welcome I'm not gonna go
that way
going down the other way right to get on
the next a banal hop another cab sure
enough as soon as I get to the corner I
see the [ __ ] guy pulled right to the
light he looks at game excite contact
and I'm like [ __ ] me leave it alone so I
I call another cab that's coming the
opposite intersection I get in it he
jumps out of his cab it's running like
meter - toward my cat okay I'm looking
at him I'm like oh god my son's like dad
who is that guy he wants to steal a cab
and we have a heist nice PJ's we have a
chance for citizen pursuit a pursuit
where my cabbage is going he jumps back
in his cab and I see him get [ __ ] cut
off I mean the look on this guy's face
as I Drive away
it was [ __ ] priceless but it was your
[ __ ] garbage but I was [ __ ]
awesome that's like a [ __ ] that's
like a trashy version of a Jim Carrey
movie yeah liar liar
so it's like I'm sort of justified in
the initial annoyance remains
yes you meant well at the moment you're
like hey you're not wrong you're not in
the wrong I'm not even slightly at that
point you know I could I've waited for
the car it just became this whole big
thing I just didn't think that was gonna
chase me did you did you have did you
have cash on you no no but if I did he's
still gonna garnish you know was that
Louis out of 20 in his pockets in the
cab peeling off 20s [ __ ] that dude [ __ ]
that that's crazy [ __ ] so you know for
all you know he could have had the
[ __ ] Apple thing disabled because he
just wants cash because in the beginning
when they started doing credit cards
like that I hate none of the drivers
wanted to take credit cards they want to
yell maybe maybe you did something like
that but he was a piece of [ __ ] so I
feel like we're involved in the easiest
confession that I've ever we think that
we didn't ask questions you you walked
in here telling us everything just
spilling your guts one time I picked up
my kid after I stole a cab and beat up a
cab driver I threatened the nurse
I killed a nun we got in the cab I used
to never wash my hands at the shop right
oh that's great
all right I got one have you ever used a
coin starter machine for less than $20
oh for sure
lutely dude I used to do that to try to
just get a pack of smokes you know what
I mean like I got eight bucks let's go
used to put them down as my financial
institution loans and [ __ ] back in the
day dude I used to [ __ ] in my Coinstar
was a regular thing I would do when I
was younger like college years of course
dude you just [ __ ] me but I remember
there's a place in Harlem right now I
don't even check cashing places are so
up and they must be but if you go to 127
there's a check cashing place and it's
like a knockoff Coinstar company I don't
know what it's called but it's like it's
not coin saw it's a knockoff company cuz
coins are machines are pretty [ __ ]
high-class this looks like the [ __ ] dude
let me tell you something all right coin
stores like a nice machine made the past
like this company still uses the first
coin cutting machine they came out in
like 83 okay this shows Liam they're
rollin I mean there's putting them in
those little rolls so this machine what
it does is this is [ __ ] psychotic you
do the coin store machine and then it
just prints out a slip with the amount
of money on it
right there's no barcode there's nothing
to scan it is like I mean you can
literally just go and take this and then
go recreate a cherry cherry cherry doggy
I'm telling you right now it was [ __ ]
I've never done it because I just I only
noticed money that badly but you can
definitely do this there's no question
because I went to Coinstar
with my kids if I can do like a piggy
banks worth a [ __ ] thing that's how I
noticed this I was like this is just as
the number you can pay me whatever it is
and there was just a busy chef cashing
place there was nobody else there was
all they would never know I'm you're not
gonna get away with taking thousands of
dollars but you could probably get away
with getting a couple hundred dollars in
one city if you're in a [ __ ] pickle
yeah that's what I would do I would step
over and I'd go thirty thousand dollars
please
[Laughter]
please small Jews if you don't mind sir
I already ordered an uberx tell it'll be
outside that's great you gentlemen pay
in Bitcoin by any chance man you don't
have anything like you can't do anything
with your toes or anything like that
Kenya like play piano or you double join
it or anything like that no cuz that's
real garbage or with a kid that could
like put his family was never prominent
and it's true dad was never running for
mayor pick his shoulder blades and like
essentially he didn't dislocate them
what he could do is just his shoulder
blades would like imagine his back is
here they would come out of his back and
they would [ __ ] it was like almost the
amount of dexterity behind his shoulder
blades
we take can't we I was in a band salty
black flour in high school and drummer
garbage drop the name of the band like
it's salty black we're gonna push the
website real quick please
so his shoulder blades if you could
imagine they would come out of his back
and they would crush a can like glumly
and they'd come back in it was like he
was like died it was crazy
Saurus yeah it was crazy what's that guy
doing now he's not like the head of
pediatrics at [ __ ] Mount Sinai or
anything like that right his dad used to
own his name was chickie blunt field and
chickie
yeah chickie and his dad should be
senior was dead he the third owned be
like shitty used-car lot not a not a
certified pre-owned or anything no no no
a one horse [ __ ] cars and have people
buy [ __ ] Carson and we do it like it was
probably trailer the office was just
like a trailer a set of stairs yeah but
my first two cars were bought from
chiquita Honda 1987 Chevy Cavalier like
a big top car yeah and then I Nissan
300zx 1986 Horst Green Jesus right shift
course like he was friends with the the
other like auto body
I don't know this real facts oh I
shouldn't say this baby so operating I'm
making the joke but this is the type of
business that it is right he knew the
guys that would do inspections like in
Rockland County yeah yeah there was a
place in Rockland County I think the
name of it literally just [ __ ] naming
names now I'm a [ __ ] rat but this
place you would go in you inspection fee
but then you just pay the guy an extra
50 bucks and he would just pass you on
inspection Jesus Christ yeah we goes by
[ __ ] cars my family always had [ __ ] cars
it would never pass the inspections and
this is the way it was the most
dangerous irresponsible thing ever
yeah my buddy was a mechanic and he used
to be able to roll back to dial his
older cars but he'd be able to control
back the that's just you figured out a
fight you know that's like a federal
crime to [ __ ] around with her oh you
know if your engine could blow up or
something like that if it has a hundred
thousand miles you say it's brand-new I
mean you're not gonna buy a 1991 [ __ ]
Honda Civic with six miles on it like
you're not gonna roll it back that much
it's still gonna happen like 70 K they
City your highway huh 1984 [ __ ]
Caprice Classic never took you know
driveway cap that's too good just a
couple more questions for you here Louis
Kippy you got one yeah have you ever I
think this has to be yes have you ever
owned a 100 this finally I found the
perfect person to ask these questions
have you ever owned a collection of any
of the following mr. gomez numchucks
yeah Chinese stars yeah finally you're
the only other person I ever met that
own Chinese stars when I was a kid if
you had a Chinese star that was like
pulled out of [ __ ] 12-inch [ __ ] it
was [ __ ] everybody back the [ __ ] up
there was a little martial arts store
that just sold children weapons in the
early 80s in the 80s and 90s you can get
your hands on weapons of the using -
sighs when I was eight I go by for a
straight-up blow gun like a blow dart
gun I do not used to have one we would
go to like the the flea market at the
racetrack at the Philadelphia racetrack
go to the flea market and they were like
darts they were like this there you know
and it was like the black tube and he
goes and dude you could [ __ ] you
could hurt a kid with that for sure yeah
you could take somebody's eye out
maybe maybe tell them if you have the
perfect aim to their throat yeah good
luck the most lethal thing that we used
to [ __ ] with was the pellet gun remember
the pellet gun
step up of the BB gun you know I think
it's trans fats with the sharpened yeah
it was like almost shaped like an
hourglass yeah was think it was lat wall
instead of like a circle was like yeah
like a slug that'll grow up reset BB gun
wars like and just we used to have ten
pump BB guns and we the rules you can
pump BB gun now hurt a little bit but
then you get crayons there were like
just [ __ ] nine pumps each but not
into each other's bodies faces it was
psychotic through the 80s and 90s we're
a [ __ ] were a different time for sure
all right I got one
have you ever gone to a bar and asked
the bartender what's the cheapest beer
not in a long time now I was the the
self-awareness to just find out what
cheapest beer was and yeah
you can you can i bawled--sometimes i
think photos tell me one time you were
at like industry or something
how much of the course lights they're
like it's an open bar you idiot he's
like alright I'll take two [ __ ] Jack
Daniels yeah I I used to go to a place
called the village idiot in New York
City when I first moved here and it was
underage drinking nineteen years old
nobody gave a [ __ ] you just go in and
yeah that place had five dollar and
fifty cent pictures of Jesus but ice I
don't [ __ ] oh my god a bar that serves
but ice but at least five dollars and
fifty cents we would sell comedy club
tickets on the street and then we would
go to this bar and get obliterated just
[ __ ] I mean so my 21st birthday there
I fell asleep in the garbage outside
welcome to 6:00 in the morning garbage
man shook me awake you are literally
garbage this is too easy
have you ever gone to a to medieval
times or a Renaissance Faire well it's
not fair yeah
have you ever have you ever hooked up
with a girl that worked at the
Renaissance Faire no most of the people
that I grew up near were racist all the
ball the white chicks that were willing
to work at a Renaissance Fair it was a
it was a weird cross-section of nerdy
people but white trash so the people
that would work at the Renaissance Fair
like they were kind of weird and kind of
nerdy and a little bit like it's almost
like Juggalos that's about the best way
Juggalos I bet you there's a lot of
jugglers that have worked there
Renaissance Fairs yeah I can see that
for sure for sure
Juggalo scare me a little bit a little
bit of that a little bit it looks like
those [ __ ] things you're just like
mayhem like people fight you can see
folly bouncing around with like one of
those big three liters of Faygo or
whatever well that's a thing those dopes
that's where I would get laid the most
those fat guys [ __ ] clothes hot
chicks at those things those guys are
disgusting
you put a little [ __ ] that clown
makeup on all sudden you're [ __ ] Brad
Pitt all right I got one more for you do
you currently like if you were to get a
phone call that you have to go you know
to a wedding tomorrow do you
a suit right now that fits you yes but
only because I just went to a wedding I
buy a new suit every time we go to over
cuz I get invited to a wedding i
fluctuate and wait so much and I get
invited to the wedding once every year
or two right and almost every time I
every time I buy see that's where I buy
it from I feel like every adult every
adult male should be able to like jump
into a suit like you should like you're
doing you know if you can't get if you
don't have a suit on hand you gotta you
gotta get something together you know
real oh I I you know I work for myself I
don't know I think I don't you know I
wear sweat pants if I can work every day
yeah and I didn't get into this business
after [ __ ] wore a suit you know the
you know Honor I have friends who
[ __ ] are Emmy winner is that when
they show up these award shows they show
up with a [ __ ] you know and sweat
pants and [ __ ] sneakers nobody gives
a [ __ ] and in my opinion that's way more
[ __ ] of a boss move then Sheldon
whatever the [ __ ] yeah bye I'm [ __ ]
better than this thing you're doing yeah
I'm not living my life by this standard
I created my own [ __ ] standard and
that's where people should be
I like that Louis Louis J Gomez dropping
gems here drop and phylogeny buddy Louis
I want to thank you so much for sitting
down after talking with this is there
anything you want to let everybody know
they don't already know it's a great
network that has 22 podcasts including
Legion skanks realize podcast believe
you knew Michael Bisping that's the
other one that I host as well
we're doing a 30-day free trial if you
use the promo code home so you can get
eight thousand hours of the funniest
podcast on the planet Andrew Dice clays
shows up there the first season of that
show he's not doing anymore we still up
there a lot of incredible show so we
check that out and supporting great
shows like this is a lot of fun it's a
great show thanks thank you sure you
don't really appreciate it buddy Kippy
you got anything yeah all my live dates
kevin ryan comedy you know no I got just
rate review subscribe share with a
friend we appreciate the support as we
get this off the ground absolutely thank
you guys so much we will see you guys
next week Luis thank you again brother
everybody make sure they check out if
they don't already which I'm sure most
people listen to this already know who
you are
- digital network thank you guys so much
Louis thank you buddy thanks guys